.
SO WE ALSO DO THE SAME.
>> Jesse: LET'S BRING IN SARAH
PALIN VICE PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE AND FORMER GOVERNOR OF
ALASKA.
GOVERNOR, THIS MUST PARTICULAR
YOU THE IRONY HERE IS PRETTY
PRETTY THICK.
ANY REACTION TO THESE 50
MIGRANTS THAT SHOWED UP AT
OBAMA'S VACATION PAD?
>> YEAH.
AND IN THE MEANTIME, ARIZONA,
TEXAS, OTHERS ARE INVITING INTO
THEIR STATE HUNDREDS EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
WE WILL HAVE 2 MILLION ILLEGAL
ALIENS COMING ACROSS OUR BORDER
THIS YEAR.
AND MARTHA'S VINEYARD, THE
ELITES THERE THEY ARE GRIPING
ABOUT 50.
THEY SPEAK OUT OF BOTH SIDES OF
THEIR MOUTH, OF COURSE, JESSE,
AND IT'S JUST LIKE WITH GUN
CONTROL, TRY TO TAKE AWAY OUR
ARMS WHILE THEIR PEEPS ARE ALL,
YOU KNOW, THEY ARE ALL FIREARMED
UP PROTECTING THEM.
IT'S JUST LIKE FENCES AND
BORDERS.
THEY ALL HAVE FENCES AROUND
THEIR PROPERTY BUT HEAVEN FORBID
THE U.S. HAS A SECURE BORDER.
AND IT -- WE HAD A RULE OF LAW
IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND THE RULE OF LAW IS THERE.
THE WHOLE CONCEPT OF IT TO
PROTECT US.
JOE SIX PACK.
THE NORMAL AMERICAN OUT THERE.
AND, YET, THEY CERTAINLY DON'T
ABIDE BY THE RULE OF LAUGH.
THEY MAKE UP THEIR OWN RULES.
IT'S JUST LIKE THEIR RULES FOR
INSIDER TRADING.
SO MANY EXAMPLES I COULD GIVE.
BUT, WE GET THE GOVERNMENT THAT
WE VOTE FOR AND HOPEFULLY THIS
WILL WAKE PEOPLE UP.
ESPECIALLY THOSE IN DEEP BLUE
STATES THAT HAVE ASKED TO BE
SANCTUARY CITIES.
FINALLY MAYBE THEY WILL START
PAYING ATTENTION.
>> Jesse: SOMEONE IS PAYING
ATTENTION.
HIS NAME IS GAVIN NEWSOM OUT
THERE IN CALIFORNIA.
HE SAYS THAT HE WANTS THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO GO
AFTER THE GOVERNORS OF TEXAS AND
FLORIDA AND CHARGE THEM WITH
KIDNAPPING.
HE WANTS TO INDICT THESE
GOVERNORS ON KIDNAPPING CHARGES
FOR SENDING THESE ILLEGAL ALIENS
ON BUS RIDES AND AIR FLIGHTS TO
THESE IDEALIC SPOTS.
>> THAT'S PAR FOR THE COURSE
NEWSOM.
THERE IN HOLLYWOOD.
IS HE SUCH AN ACTOR AND HAS TO
DRAMATIZE SOMETHING LIKE THAT SO
WE WILL TALK ABOUT HIM.
THE GUY IS GOOFY.
I FEEL SORRY FOR THE GOOD PEOPLE
WHO LIVE IN CALIFORNIA AND I
SPEAK TO SO MANY OF THEM,
FRIENDS OF MINE THERE, WHO CAN'T
BELIEVE WHAT GAVIN GETS AWAY
WITH.
THAT'S KIND OF IS TYPICALLY OF
HIM TO SAY SUCH A THING.
BUT, WOW, THAT KIND OF TAKES THE
CAKE HOW GOOFY THAT ONE IS.
>> Jesse: HE DOESN'T SAY A WORD
ABOUT THE CARTELS WHERE ALL THE
HUMAN SMUGGLING AND KIDNAPPING
AND DRUG DEALING BUT IT'S THE
GOVERNORS.
>> JESSE, THE FENTANYL, THE
PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER AND IT'S NOT
JUST THE ILLEGAL ALIENS THAT --
THIS MASSIVE HUMANITARIAN CRISIS
IS BEING CREATED BY THE LEFT
INVITING ILLEGALS IN.
SOMEBODY HAS TO TAKE CARE OF
THEM.
RIGHT?
BUT IT'S NOT JUST THE PEOPLE.
IT'S WHAT THEY ARE BRINGING
OVER.
FENTANYL.
AND THAT'S KILLING MORE PEOPLE
IN A CERTAIN DEMOGRAPHIC.
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE THAN ANY OTHER
CAUSE OF DEATH.
ALL THE PROBLEMS COMING OVER THE
BORDER IT'S ON BIDEN'S
SHOULDERS.
AND I CALL ON CONGRESS TO STOP
THIS BIDEN AGENDA THAT ALLOWS
PART OF THE FUNDAMENTAL
TRANSFORMATION OF AMERICA,
ALLOWS THE OPEN BORDERS THAT
INCENTIVIZING PEOPLE TO COME ON
OVER.
AND NOW, YEAH.
THEY ARE WHINING ABOUT THE 50,
YEAH.
FLEW IN OR RODE IN ON AIR
CONDITIONED BUSES AND, YEAH,
THEY CAN'T HANDLE THAT.
SO, IT'S, YOU KNOW, RULES FOR
THE REST OF US AS PEONS WHILE
THE ELITES THEY GET TO SKATE.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT.
GREAT ICE CREAM PARLORS IN EDGAR
TOWN.
I SUGGEST ALL THE MIGRANTS GO
THERE.
PISTAC